grammys everybody are you ready for
grammys i'm so excited
too i really am and in fact we're going
to gear up with a true expert
and a very dear friend of our show i
feel like we're almost doing this like
weekly and i can't get enough
it's the host of entertainment tonight
now in its 40th season kevin frazier
hi kevin andrew hey ross how are you
guys doing how are y'all doing
we are great we are excited about sunday
yeah we all need it it's going to be a
great night
i think it'll be a great night yeah i
mean it's music's biggest night
and there's so much to talk about trevor
noah is hosting my favorite
kevin let's get right in with the biggie
it's record of the year
there are so many great songs in this
category but i believe
that the winner will be the savage remix
those two houston natives dropped a
record that appealed to people
regardless of race creed or color
and here's the interesting thing beyonce
the solo artist
has never won record of the year i know
i think
that drought finally ends i think if
this is her year even though
there are a lot of great songs in this
category and a lot of great performers
and you look at dua lipa and you know
you say oh wow can do a leap of win this
year but
i really think this is beyonce and
megan's to lose i think you're right
kevin
yeah i do love circles by post malone
though i can't get that one out of my
head and it was such a big song this
whole year they owe beyonce one or two
so just
give her this award this song was great
i thought maybe she'd celebrate
she would just win it based on that but
i think the megan the stallion potent
combination
is like a double down on greatness
we took an online poll on our facebook
uh for the show
and we haven't heard the results yet
kevin so we're gonna hear him here with
you are you ready
okay let's i'm curious what is it
what is it oh everything i wanted by
billy eilish came out on top i get it
i get it totally such an incredible song
look circle's in second place though um
billy was the big
winner at the grammys last year uh and
she could repeat this year
oh yeah i do think that has an effect
although
when we talk about album of the year i'm
going to go back on those words because
it's another category that's totally
stacked ross you're out totally well you
have
a taylor swift coldplay do alipa haim um
but here's the real question can anybody
beat
taylor swift she is the queen of the
grammys if she were to win album of the
year this would be her
third time doing so the first woman to
ever do that
kev can anyone beat her i i don't think
so but if anyone will come close it's
doualipa i think that the grammy voters
really do
love her and this album was bouncy and
infectious and it was the kind of thing
that you could either play at a party or
just in your car when you wanted to
bounce around going to work
i think that um you know coldplay uh it
was great it was a it's a good album but
i
think that at the end of the day this is
taylor's award to lose and
the grammy voters love taylor because
she takes you on a journey
she tells you a story and all of her
songs have
have have a little bit of truth in them
that always make us
uh want to listen and speculate what is
she really talking about yeah
it's a tough one because she is you know
always a favorite and you're right that
you can't deny taylor swift she's this
good
you know i agree with you i think that
also this year as
always you come to the grammys for the
musical performances now it'll be a
little different because
it'll be more straight up performances
um instead of
what you used to have as these eclectic
weird mashups of people
this year you'll see people just
performing um harry styles is going to
open up the show
and there will be five stages in the
round all around sprinkled around the
convention center and there are going to
be some amazing performers billy eilish
cardi b bts meg the stallion
um it will be an exciting year because
you will have
all of the performers and the nominees
there that's who will be in the audience
around those circular stages
you will have the all the different
nominees so maybe while meg is
performing she can look down and see
the baby and taylor swift when harry
opens up the show you know
he'll look over and he'll see billy
eilish right there so it will be
star-studded
i admire that the grammys is really
going to bring it
i think people need this and some of the
award shows
you know there's been a little bit of a
disconnect zoom wise
and i think this is going to kind of
surge us out of there i think we're
going to need it and the grammys are
always
so fun kevin we've been on the red
carpet we've covered them
there's they're always risky too and you
know i know you brought us
uh some yeah look backs at incredible
moments from grammy's over the years
right
i've got to start with the dress that
made google explode
jlo's versace from 2000 i mean
when she hit the carpet with that it's
crazy right
i don't remember that black piece of
fabric you know you're watching a
daytime show when you've got
that going on epic though i mean that
was
that's how you do a carpet right i mean
it
changed everything iconic dress yes and
you're right it changed everything and
it changed also
about the way we looked at j.lo it
turned her into this
fashion icon show stopper wouldn't you
agree drew i
agree a thousand percent she's amazing
can we jump to 2002. paddy labelle
her surprise when she brought out the
new ladies of lady marmalade
um with pink maya christina
and little kim oh and missy elliott yeah
that was just
it was special it was cool it was
different and to have miss patty there
and
i was around and i was alive for the
first
version of it so to see the second
version mixed with the first
was magical hey can we jump to 2010 pink
really could join cirque du soleil yeah
and when she flew
through the air with that aerial
performance it was special
she earned a standing ovation because
everybody was just like whoa whoa whoa
what yeah sometimes it's just nice to
see a live performance but this was a
true
performance and that level of commitment
and effort and energy and skill set that
she put into that
was just the biggest drop the mic moment
ever i have youtube this probably 2500
times
uh because it gives me all the feels
when i watch it it is my favorite grammy
performance ever
i love pink for everything she does now
can i tell y'all
this was my craziest grammy moment
because i was standing on the red carpet
when lady gaga arrived in that egg
and my whole thing was like can she
breathe i was like what is going on
y'all
like we were literally losing our mind
because we were like
is she okay because as you can see the
egg was starting to steam up a little
bit
and so i was like is she gonna make it i
it was just so mind-blowing it was out
of left field i didn't know what to do
or what to think can i ask you a
question up close was this egg all it
was cracked up to be
everett it was everything and more
because you were just like what
is going on what what
i i i can't love it more i'm just like
yes
thank you i i just love when lady gaga
comes out as a man
or in an egg meat dress yes i you know
what
this is what artistry and performance is
about we need
that david bowie level of like what are
they going to do next it's what
made madonna she reinvented herself it's
exciting
now kevin can we jump to adele in 2017
that was something in 2017 when she won
for album of the year and she was so
excited and then she was just
she looked down at beyonce and she said
this award should have gone
to beyonce's lemonade and it was really
a cool moment that she
took time out to to give a little love
um to someone who she admires and that
was adele 2017 was adele's year it was
her night
and so i thought it was beautiful and it
was just a great moment of once again
solidarity and
you know artists shouting out other
artists and women recognizing other
women
it was women supporting women it was
women admiring each other it was a
shared moment and it was perfection
agreed well kevin can't wait for sunday
i can't wait until we meet again
hopefully it'll be next week it's never
soon enough and you can catch kevin
on weeknights on entertainment tonight
[Music]
you